The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so today we're
going to start talking about
acids and bases, and this is
acid-base equilibrium, so you
can't forget anything that
you've learned from the last
two lectures about
equilibrium.
And then we're going to talk
about, after this, oxidation
reduction equilibrium, and
so there's a lot of
equilibrium going on.
So today we're going to give
you some definitions.
We're going to talk about
autoionization of water.
We're going to talk about the
p h function, which most
people are familiar with.
We may think about what the p
h's are of some commonly found
ingredients around campus.
And talk about the strengths
of those acids and bases.
And then if we have time, we'll
start thinking about how
to work a problem associated
with a weak acid.
So actually, I guess, do we want
to do that other clicker
question, maybe, before
we get started?
At some point, we're going to
ask you a question about when
you want forums. So, I'm not
sure if we're going to have
that for you today or not, but
we need to -- we want to have
these pizza forums where you can
come, and the time isn't
always working, so we thought
we could use the clickers to
figure out what the best
time is for people.
So we may have that
for you later.
So this is the narrowest
definition of
an acid and a base.
So the narrowest definition of
an acid and a base is that an
acid is a substance when you
dissolve it in water, it
increases the concentration of
hydrogen ions, or h plus.
Whereas a base is a substance
that when dissolved in water,
increases the concentration of
hydroxide ions, or o h minus.
So that's pretty narrow.
We can be broader.
We can talk about
Bronsted-Lowry, and here, an
acid is described as a substance
that can donate a
hydrogen ion.
And a base is described as a
substance that can accept a
hydrogen ion.
So let's look at some examples
using that definition.
So let's look at an example, so
c h 3, c o o h plus water,
and I guess I should put that in
aqueous, going to hydronium
ion plus c h 3, c o
o minus aqueous.
All right, so what
is going on here?
So if we look at the things on
one side of the equation and
the other, you can see that this
is an acid that has lost
its hydrogen ion, so the
hydrogen is gone, whereas the
water molecule has gained a
hydrogen ion, and so now it's
h 3 o plus.
So we have an acid here, it's
acting as an acid, and acid
acts as a substance that gives
up a hydrogen ion, and the
water is acting as a base,
it's accepting
that hydrogen ion.
And when it accepts the hydrogen
ion, it becomes an
acid in the reverse direction,
whereas when the acid gives
off the hydrogen ion,
it becomes a base
in the reverse direction.
So in the reverse direction,
hydronium ions is giving off a
hydrogen ion to this base,
reforming the acid, and after
a hydronium ion gives off
its hydrogen ion,
it forms water again.
So that would be an example of
Bronsted-Lowry talking about
substances as acids and bases
whether they accept or donate
a hydrogen ion.
And this is the definition we're
going to be using mostly
throughout this unit.
So, let's look at a little
movie of this going on.
So, in this movie, we have our
water molecules with red and
the white dots here are their
hydrogen atoms, and now we're
going to come in and have an
acid come in, there's the
acid, it has the hydrogen
ion on it in white.
It meets up with a water
molecule, and now you formed
hydronium ion.
And that forms another water
molecule and it passes it
along, so there's a different
molecule of hydronium ion.
So that's what's going on
in this definition.
All right.
So this brings us to another
term, which is conjugate acid
base pairs, so you can talk
about something being a
conjugate base of a particular
acid, and so a conjugate base
of an acid is a base that's
formed after the acid has
donated its hydrogen ion.
A conjugate acid of a base is
the acids that its formed when
the base accepts the
hydrogen ion.
So you can look at those
examples here.
So we have a pair that we've
drawn here with this red line,
an acid base pair, and the other
pair is the water and
the hydronium ion.
All right, let's look at a
couple more examples to get
the sense of this and
figure out what are
the acid base pairs.
So, one more example.
So now let's look at h c o 3
minus an aqueous solution and
water, going to, again,
hydronium ion, and c o 3 minus
2, also an aqueous solution.
So, what is h c o 3 minus
acting as here?
As an acid.
And so what does that
make water?
A base.
And so the conjugate acid of
that base, again, is the
hydronium ion concentration.
And the conjugate base
of the acid is c o 3
minus 2, over here.
And so in the reverse direction,
this base will be
accepting a hydrogen ion from
the acid, forming the
conjugates on the other side.
OK, now you can do an example.
Let's have a clicker question.
So identify what the acid and
the base pairs are here.
All right, let's take
10 seconds.
That's quite good actually.
So, that's correct and you can
write it in your notes that
here we see that there's a
little bit of change, water's
doing something different.
So instead of the conjugate of
water being the hydronium ion,
we see it's a hydroxide.
So here, the water is acting
as an acid giving off a
hydrogen ion to this
h c o 3 minus.
And so now we have a second
hydrogen ion over here, we
have the h 2 species, and that
the conjugate of water is o h.
So this is acting as a base,
it's accepting a hydrogen ion,
this is donating it, it's an
acid, this is the conjugate
acid of that base, and
this is the conjugate
base of that acid.
So in the reverse direction,
this is an acid giving off a
hydrogen ion to the hydroxide
forming water.
So one thing that you'll notice
about these examples
that we've written up is that
when you see water in the
equation, you don't really know
what it's going to be
doing until you actually look
at what the products are and
then you can figure it out.
So water can act as either
an acid or a
base in these equations.
And if we go to the lecture
notes, the term is amphoteric,
which is a molecule that can
act as either an acid or a
base, depending on the
reaction conditions.
So depending on if it's mixed
with something that's a
stronger acid or a stronger
base than it is.
And an example, one of the most
common examples is water.
So now let's consider a broader
example of acids and
bases, and these are Lewis acids
and bases, and we're
going to actually come back to
this around Thanksgiving time
when we talk about transition
metals.
And so here it's really broad
-- we're not actually even
going to talk about a
hydrogen ion at all.
So in this case, we're talking
about a Lewis base as a
species that donates lone pair
electrons, and a Lewis acid is
a species that accepts
such electrons.
So here would be an example.
So we can think about forming a
complex, and which thing is
going to act as an
acid or a base.
One will be donating its lone
pair electrons and the other
will be accepting.
So this is a very broad, a much
broader definition, and
so when you talk about acid base
here, so always say as a
Lewis acid or Lewis base to make
it clear what's going on.
So again we have our base
donating its lone pair
electrons and the
acid accepting.
All right, so those are
our definitions
of acids and bases.
So now let's come back to this
issue of water and how water
can act as an acid or a base.
So if it can act as an acid or
a base, it seems like it can
react with itself to do some
chemistry, and it can.
So up here, you could have one
water molecule acting as an
acid, giving up its hydrogen ion
to another water acting as
a base, forming hydronium
ion and also
forming hydroxide ion.
So then you can ask the
question, well, how much h 2 o
is in a typical glass
of water.
How much, so you don't like
the idea that I'm drinking
hydroxide ions, how much
hydronium ion and how much
hydroxide ion are in this glass
of water, how much h 2 o
is in a glass of water?
So that's the question.
So here's the equation again,
and we can think about how to
calculate it.
What do we really want to
know in this question?
What are we really asking?
How much, at an equilibrium
situation, how much are
products and how much reactants
do you have?
What can you tell me about
ratios of products and
reactants at equilibrium?
K. And how are some ways
you can calculate k's?
Different terms, but, right,
it's what about -- what is k?
So we have the equilibrium
constant, and there a couple
different ways one might
calculate k -- you might be
given concentrations at
equilibrium, or you might be
given information
about delta g.
So you can calculate k's from
delta g nought, and this is an
equation that you'll use pretty
often -- delta g nought
equals minus r t natural
log of k.
So if we want to know k, we
need to find out what
delta g nought is.
What are ways to calculate
delta g?
So you've seen some of those
-- oh, you're probably
recognizing these already,
temperature and our gas constant.
So we can solve for k
in terms of delta g.
And how do we calculate
that delta g.
Well, there are a
couple of ways.
So you can think about the delta
g's of formations, and
we can think about one of my
personal favorites, which is
relationship between delta
h and t delta s.
So you can think about your
enthalpies and your entropies
at a certain temperature, and
you can calculate delta g, and
from that you can get the
equilibrium constant.
So this is just a little review
showing the relevance
of material you've learned
before to the material we're
covering now.
So we're going to pick one and
just calculate the delta g.
So we can look up these values
of formation for our products
and our reactants and plug them
in, and we get a value
for delta g nought
of plus 79 .
89 kilojoules per mole.
So we have a positive
value here.
So without doing any more math,
which we'll do it a
minute, do you expect a large
or small value for k for the
equilibrium constant if delta
g nought is positive 79 .
89 kilojoules per mole.
STUDENT: Small.
PROFESSOR: We would expect
it to be small.
And you probably already knew
that that there's a lot of h 2
o in a glass of water.
So again, from that perspective,
we'd also expect
it to be small.
So now we can plug those values
in, we calculated this
delta g, we know the gas
constant, we're at room
temperature, and so we get
a value of k as 1 .
0 times 10 to the minus 14 at
room temperature, and that's a
small number.
So, the very small value
indicates that only a small
percentage all your h 2 0 has
ionized, and that mostly,
there's h 2 o in a glass of
water, not so many ions.
Not many of the molecules have
ionized, because k is a small
number, not a lot of products
at this equilibrium.
So there's a lot of h 2
o in a glass of water.
So, this particular k has
a special name, and
it's k w, w for water.
And this term and this number,
if you haven't memorized it in
high school, you probably will
by the time you're done with
problem-sets.
This is a very valuable number,
you'll be using it a
lot in calculating acid base
problems, and you will end up
memorizing it whether
you want to or not.
So, then k w equals your
hydronium ion concentration
times your hydroxide
ion concentration.
Now for a minute, let's consider
why that's true.
So our reaction, it's products
over reactants for an
equilibrium constant, but now,
all of a sudden, I don't have
my reactants going on in here.
So the k w is expressed in terms
of the concentration a
hydronium ions times the
concentration of hydroxide,
and it doesn't have this water
term at the bottom.
And that'll be true for
any problem in which
the water is a solvent.
And so, it's really not going
to be changing very much.
A solvent is nearly pure, and
when you have in a nearly pure
solvent or solid, it's not
included in the equilibrium
expression.
So we'll see other examples
of this as we go along.
So you always want to ask
yourself is this the solvent.
If so, we're talking about very
dilute things going on in
solvent, the solvent
concentration isn't changing
very much, so it drops
out of our term.
So, because k w is an
equilibrium constant, the
products are always going to be
equal to the same thing at
the same temperature.
So, at room temperature, or 298
kelvin, it's always going
to be equal to 1 .
0 times 10 to the minus 14,
and that's why it's such a
valuable number.
And when we're talking about
acid base problems, you're
almost always going to be at
room temperature, just to not
make life more complicated
for you.
So, you can pretty much assume,
it should be in big
bold letters if the temperature
is not room
temperature, so that you
can use these values.
All right, so let's look at
the p h function now.
So what does p h equal?
So p h is equal to the minus the
log of the hydronium ion
concentration, and let's also
talk about p o h, and that's
equal to minus log of the
hydroxide ion concentration.
I just told you that k w is
equal to the concentration of
hydronium ions times
the concentration
of hydroxide ions.
And now we can express
this in another very
useful way for you.
If we take the log of all sides,
actually let's take the
minus log of everything, so
minus log of k w equals the
minus log of hydronium ion
concentration, minus the log
of hydroxide ion concentration,
and we end up
with terms of p k w being equal
to p h, because minus
log of the hydronium ion
concentration is p h, and
minus the log of the hydroxide
concentration is p o h.
So plus p o h.
And we know that this term at
room temperature is 1 .
0 times 10 to the minus 14.
So this term at room
temperature is 14 .
0 0, again at 25 degrees
c or 298 kelvin.
So this is also a useful
expression.
If you know the p h, you can
calculate the p o h if you're
at room temperature, remembering
this number of 14.
So these are things that you
will be doing a lot in the
problems and you will start
remembering all of these
numbers really well.
So p h and p o h, what
does p h do for you?
Well, the p h tells you about
the strength of the acid.
So the p h of pure water should
be neutral, which is 7.
And now, tell me what the
p h of an acid is and
the p h of a base.
Let's just do 10 seconds
on this, this is pretty
straightforward.
So this tests previous knowledge
on this topic, and
it is very good.
People know about what
the p h's are.
So that's right.
So the p h of an acid solution
is less than 7, and the p h of
a base solution is
greater than 7.
And the EPA defines corrosive as
something where the p h is
lower than 3 or greater
than 12 .
5.
So, if here is our scale of p
h, we're neutral at 7, we're
acidic below 7, and we're
corrosive below 3.
We're basic above 7, and
corrosive above 12 .
5.
So now what I want to do is ask
Dr. Taylor to come up and
we're going to measure some p
h's of things, so we're going
to be interested in knowing
how much danger you're in
around MIT.
So we're going to have
you measure them.
We have these little strips on
it, and so someone will come
around and help you read it, so
you can read off the strip
of what you have. Should
we start with water?
This is random MIT water.
Let's start there.
So, just pick a volunteer.
PROFESSOR: OK, so what we're
going to do is have the TA's
go in and ask you to read off
of a p h strip, what the p h
of various things are, and
actually Marcus, if you could
write on the board
what these are.
So we'll start with MIT water.
So, we know if it's 7 it's
neutral, if it's below 7 we're
talking about acidic, and
above that it's basic.
We actually, also for you to be
able to visualize as well,
what I did is I just boiled up
some cabbage last night and
brought in the extract
with me.
And cabbage actually has
anthocyanins in it, which is a
color indicator, and it changes
color based on whether
it's in an acidic or
a basic solution.
So we'll let you
see this here.
It looks like MIT water,
pretty safe to drink,
which is good news.
We can go ahead and -- so it
looks like if we add MIT water
to cabbage solution, what do you
think's going to happen --
this is neutral right now.
Hopefully not much.
We either have invalid
strips or we'll see
nothing happen here.
All right, so you can see we
still have the purple color
for MIT water.
Two confirmations that it's safe
to drink right out of the
tap when you get home.
So, the next thing is
vinegar did someone
take the, the strip?
STUDENT: We have
a 2 and a 1/2.
PROFESSOR: OK, so are
we drinking vinegar?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR: Probably
not straight.
All right, so we've
got our cabbage
extract here, it's purple.
Does anyone have a guess as to
what color it's going to turn
if we pour in vinegar,
very acidic.
All right, a couple guesses
I hear, blue and pink.
They're both good guesses
because different color
indicators turn different
colors.
But, all right, looks like a
dramatic difference here.
What do we have next
out there?
Baking soda.
Seven for the baking soda.
I'm going to guess we did not
pour in enough or it is not
dissolved here.
All right, so let's do our
secondary test here and see
what happens with
the baking soda.
PROFESSOR: [UNINTELLIGIBLE] the
water we added it to was
also not neutral.
PROFESSOR: All right, so we're
actually pretty basic with the
baking soda.
We won't give it a number
because it was just
dissolved in water.
But we'll remember baking soda,
blue here is basic.
So the next thing we're going to
test is soda that you drink
all the time.
I brought Sprite.
Coke probably would have
been a good pick as
well or Diet Coke.
So, we'll test what that is.
Hopefully it comes out
neutral, right?
So while we're waiting, we'll
start taking a little
bit of a look here.
All right, we've got a 3.
Soda, corrosive.
It's not just the sugar that's
bad for your teeth.
Luckily we see here it is not
quite as bad as vinegar in
terms of how acidic it is, but
we definitely have a color
change here.
PROFESSOR: Has anyone
used soda for
something other than drinking?
What did you use it for?
STUDENT: Cleaning pennies.
PROFESSOR: Cleaning pennies,
what else?
STUDENT: When you have stuff all
over your car battery you
can use Coke.
PROFESSOR: And some of those
other uses make sense.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
What else?
STUDENT: Taking the
galvanization
off of a steel wire.
PROFESSOR: OK, so cleaning
steel wire.
How many of you still drink soda
knowing this information?
PROFESSOR: All right, so the
next thing we put out there
was aspirin dissolved in water,
and it's going to
depend what concentration we
did, but we put aspirin in
water and we got a 3 here.
So, aspirin sometimes gives
you an upset stomach, and
that's why Tylenol's an
improvement in some ways --
obviously, that has its
own drawbacks, too.
But you can see what your
stomach on aspirin might be
feeling like here.
So if you're having an upset
stomach, something you might
do is take Tums or Mylanta or
some other kind of a -- yeah,
let's measure the p h here.
So if you decide to take some
Milk of Magnesia after an
upset stomach, are you
hoping it will be
acidic or basic here?
STUDENT: Basic.
PROFESSOR: All right, let's
see what we get.
All right, so this is
kind of thicker.
Let's see how this works.
I think you can start to see
the green at the bottom.
So, it's white in here, so
this is not just color.
So we'll let that
slowly mix in.
What did we get for a p h, if
you can read it on there.
This might be another no-go.
STUDENT: It says 7, but--
PROFESSOR: It's probably
blue--
PROFESSOR: So, how many people
have had lunch yet today?
How many are going to
have lunch soon?
How many are reconsidering what
they're going to eat for
lunch based on this demo?
PROFESSOR: Al right, we'll take
a look at one last thing
that you might be consuming.
Lemon juice, or actually this
is lime juice here.
All right, we're probably ending
with an easy one here.
What do you think, acidic or
basic for the lime juice.
So, really, the question is
probably just the shade that
we're going to get from going
from a purple here.
All right, so what are we
reading for the lime juice?
A 2, OK.
PROFESSOR: OK, so that's the
end of our demo here,
providing you with some tips
about what is corrosive and
what is not corrosive
around MIT.
And I think the title of this
lecture on the syllabus is "is
it safe to drink the water at
MIT," and the answer is a lot
safer than drinking soda.
So let's talk about some acids
in water some more, and
introduce something you'll use
a lot, which is an acid
ionization constant.
So let's look at an example
of an acid in water.
So say we have c h 3, c o o h
aqueous, so it's in water,
which is our solvent.
It's acting as an acid, so it's
giving off a hydrogen ion
to water forming hydronium
ion, and forming its
conjugate, which is missing
its hydrogen ion.
All right, so here we have an
equation, and now we're going
to introduce something which
is the acid ionization
constant, or k a, and you'll
be using k a a lot in this
course, we're also going to
have some k b's for bases.
So the acid ionization
constant.
And it's an equilibrium
constant, so you all know how
to write equilibrium
constants.
So the equilibrium constant is
going to be products, which in
this case is hydronium ions
times the concentration of the
conjugate base of the acid
over the conjugate acid.
And there is no water in that
equation, because here the
water is pretty much pure.
It's the solvent so its
concentration is not going to
change very much, so
it is left off.
And I can tell you that
the ionization
constant here is 1 .
76 times 10 to the minus 5.
Again, that's temperature
dependent, so
that's at 25 degrees.
This is a small number, so that
tells us this is not a
very strong acid.
So it's not ionizing very
much in solution.
That is a definition of a weak
acid, something that doesn't
ionize very much.
The definition of a strong acid
is something that does
ionize quite a bit.
So here then, we can write
equations generically for
acids and bases.
You can write an equation
generically, h a being as your
acid, plus water, goes to
hydronium ions, and your
conjugate of the acid,
which is a minus.
So this is an acid,
h a, in water.
We can also write it as h b plus
as an acid in water going
to hydronium ion concentrations
and the
conjugate, which is base, it's
lost its hydrogen ion as well.
A strong acid is something
that has a k a
greater than one.
More products than reactant
at equilibrium.
So that means it ionizes almost
completely, so it goes
far toward products, ionizes
almost completely.
A weak acid is something with a
k a of less than one, which
means that when you put this
acid in water, it doesn't
ionize very much, when
you have equilibrium.
So you can tell if something
is a strong acid or not by
looking at it's k a value, or
alternatively you can consider
something called p k a.
So the p k a is minus log of the
k a, and if you have a low
value of k a, you'll have a
higher p k a, and the higher
the p k a then, the
weaker the acid.
So you can look it k a or you
can think about p k a in terms
of whether something is
a strong acid or not.
And so we'll just finish
up with this slide.
So, up here we have some
very strong acids.
These k a's are much greater
than one, and you have
extremely low values
for p k a.
And if you keep going from
strong acids, again, a strong
acid has a k a greater than one,
so these are all strong.
And so, then weak acids
are less than one.
And so down here you'd have
small numbers for k a, and so
-- up here we have big k a's,
here we have smaller k a's,
and the corresponding p k a's
are going up, and if we keep
going, this table is very long,
we're going to get some
very high p k a values
when you have some
very, very small numbers.
OK, we'll stop there for
today and continue
acid base next time.